i'm joined with a very interesting guest
today i'm excited to
invite him um ana mesh singh is here to
talk to us about
cube flow and i'm going to introduce
anamesh in a minute but before i do that
i just wanted to
send a special thank you to our sponsor
ibm ibm has been supporting data council
this year 2020 um throughout our
online events and uh and community
meetup community and so we're very
excited to have their support
ibm is a big supporter of the open
source community
and they have a special data science
community with online resources
content and support for data
professionals
and you can check that out at the link
that we'll put in the chat
alongside this episode so do check them
out um
i know they were offering a free online
course
for registrants um so i hope that you'll
take advantage of that
and enjoy the resources that they have
on display there
um secondly i wanted to just do a quick
announcement and mention to folks who
are listening and tuning in that
um if you haven't joined us before you
know that
or you you might not know that this is a
bit of a special format where
we encourage folks to ask questions in
the chat um alongside
the the broadcast as we're as i'm
chatting with
on a mesh so um please come prepared
with your kubeflow questions and
we'll try and fit them in usually we get
some great questions and it helps us
sort of
shift and and move the course of the
show so
it's appreciated and you know we want
this to be a dynamic
two-way resource and medium so please
feel free to type in your questions
that you have prepared um finally
as a as a final note if you want to be
notified
of these episodes when they stream
obviously we send out emails and many of
you are on our email list
and have signed up for these sessions
previously but if you want to just go
through the youtube plumbing
you can do that as well and you can make
sure that you're a subscriber to the
data council channel and there's also a
little bell icon and if you click on
that
you can actually set your notification
level so you can be notified every time
that we go live with a new dc
thursday in case you want to be notified
in real time and tune in that way
so as i mentioned anamesh thing is here
and anamesh has had a pretty
amazing career at ibm he's been in ibm
for 15 years
um anamesh now you're the chief
architect and program director
for the ai and ml platform um and of
course you're working on kubeflow which
we'll talk about but i know that you've
had meaningful contributions to
kubernetes the kubernetes ecosystem
you're also involved in ai ethics um and
other
um important uh topics right now that
are very timely
but i just wanted to hear a little bit
from you like what tell us a little bit
about your the story of your career at
ibm
and and how has that morphed and changed
over time
yeah thanks pete and thanks first of all
you know for having me here
um it has been a great journey at ibm
right obviously
you know 15 years is long time right but
by virtue of you know being in a part of
ibm which has always been at the
forefront of
cutting-edge technologies right it has
been constantly
shifting uh in terms of you know the the
technologies i mean i started working
on cloud when it was in early very early
nascent stage
you know the the journey with ibm and
with customers
on first you know set of private cloud
products
both on the infrastructure as a service
space platform as a service space then
moving towards you know public cloud
uh with bluemix uh which was based on
top of cloud foundry right so that's
that
also was the time right where uh you
know
there was a strategic shift uh in in our
part of the group in ibm right to do
more and more
on cloud with open source and as part of
that right cloud foundry was
one big uh technology which we adopted
so i played a big role
in that and ibm administered heavily in
terms of creating a platform as a
service
on top of cloud format and then you know
uh the journey moved on
uh until you know uh kubernetes came in
and i think that probably was the time
right where
uh you know i sort of realized we have
or i have done you know spent enough
years in the cloud it's
uh probably has reached a sense of
maturity where you know
the next big innovation so to say is
probably you know years away
so you know data and i started exciting
more
uh and that's where you know i i started
working more on the data and ai side of
things and i've been leading you know
quite a large number of efforts
uh within ibm around distributed
training platforms
uh you know model serving platform uh
model management and governance
ai ethics as you mentioned around
fairness adversarial robustness
explainability
and you know also working very closely
with red hat right with
uh the acquisition of red hat the
importance of open source within ibm has
obviously you know gone
10 folds more there's a lot of activity
where we are you know
ensuring that the basis the basic open
source technologies which we are
adopting
right are our sound uh we are aligned
and you know we are working together and
jointly in terms of you know
growing them so yeah that in short you
know summarizes uh
you know the journey on cloud and data
on the eyesight
that's great well we've had ibm speakers
and participants
at our community over the years um i
think before your group was called
kodai it was the advanced spark research
center
or something something to that effect
and i know we had
um some great committers to spark and
others who have
joined us over the years so it's been a
great relationship and
i'm glad to have you here and and thank
you for taking time to talk to us
yeah and just a bit on the group right
definitely i mean it previously
was called spark technology center right
so yes you know there was a strong
motion
uh you know towards spark
and we still have you know quite a bit
of committers and contributions towards
spark
uh right but you know with kode coming
into picture code stands for center for
open source data ena technologies
uh with that coming in picture you know
the mission has expanded to
uh you know the whole data ai life cycle
right so we contribute to projects like
you know tensorflow
uh pytorch uh queue flow uh
around trusted ai ethics but then you
know also around
things like area which is a metadata
governance uh data catalog which is you
know becoming very popular in its own
right so it's spread across projects you
know across the data ai life cycle
and you know there are significant
contributions uh uh we are currently you
know the second largest contributor in
queue flow
we have been at many times for many
spark releases the second largest
contributor to spark
uh fourth largest contributor to
tensorflow right so there is you know
strong sense of contribution
from the team right in open source
around data and ai
that's great um well let's
let's use that as a segway to talk about
kubeflow because
as you mentioned kubeflow is an
industry-wide
supported by industry by consortium of
amazing companies
and ibm has significant
investments and contributions as do
google microsoft facebook cisco
bloomberg
so many folks i think it's quite
remarkable because not many open source
projects that i'm aware of have so much
support
across so many different types of cloud
vendors and folks really betting on ai
and machine learning and the future of
data in their businesses so
um it's a pretty amazing group i'm sure
sometimes it's like herding cats and
it's hard to like get everyone to agree
and
move forward according to what i read
kubeflow was open sourced officially in
december 2017 but you just had a 1.0
release in march of this year so
congrats on that
um i'm sure there's some story about
like
you know what what went on behind the
scenes and um when the engineers beat
themselves over you know you beat each
other over the head to
to know that it was ready to ship
instead of just you know continue to
to fix stuff and and um but anyway uh
i'm kind of interested to hear um how
cute flow came to exist
and what the background story of it is
since i know you've been involved for
quite a while
yeah no um pretty interesting right i
mean
a lot of the right points you touched
right so it was december of 2017.
uh kubecon right so where david r and
check
if you folks don't know right he's uh he
was in google
uh you know a strong force behind qfloor
and currently you know
working in in microsoft right so he was
giving a session at cubecorn around you
know running tensorflow and kubernetes
right i mean so
um kubernetes was hot it's hard
tensorflow was becoming hot at that time
right and
there was this problem to be solved
right how to get you know scalable
tensorflow running on top of communities
right so when you're
doing distributed training uh you have
out of the box integration right so that
that in essence was you know the crux of
the idea right it was the session a demo
that hey
if you want to run test blog kubernetes
right um
this is how you get started and then
slowly it started expanding right in a
sense that
you know the adoption and maturity of
kubernetes started
um going you know many folds a lot of
enterprises
a lot of fortune 500 companies you know
started standardizing on communities a
lot of cloud providers right um
started standardizing on kubernetes and
then you know
the problem they shifted to okay we need
to run you know machine learning and ai
workloads on top of kubernetes
so even though you know the the origin
was with tensorflow and kubernetes you
know it quickly expanded okay now let's
bring pytash
and then you know there are community
members who wanted scikit-learn and
actually boost
right so that started you know forming a
conglomeration right which is okay if
you need to run
uh you know distributed training on top
of kubernetes using these technologies
here flow is
is being positioned there but that's
where it didn't stop right
uh obviously training is a very big and
important part of the life cycle but
there are things which need to happen
before training
and after training right so things like
you know a lot of the times you know uh
data scientists
they start their work using something
like jupiter notebooks
right so initially we started with
jupiter hub
at some point along the journey uh we
decided to
phase out jupiter hub and and rewrite
and have
geoflow's own implementation of
launching jupiter notebooks on top of
communities
so that become one project in itself and
then you know it started shifting
towards the rest of the umbrella which
is okay
uh you know you have a way to
start uh creating your models uh running
distributed training
but then you know you need to deploy
your models in production right so
that's another interesting story i gave
a talk at kubecon
uh december 2018 that was a year after
you know
uh q flow was launched um
that time you know 1080 has been
recently launched and we were exploring
uh in terms of running serverless model
inferencing right
on top of k native so the
talk at kubecon was uh you know focused
on this area
if you need to leverage k native right
as a service model inferencing platform
and very interestingly you know uh alice
as he's known now right he was also
attending that talk
he he was in google currently you know
part of amazon and you know he came and
said that you know he has been thinking
along a similar lines
uh in parallel bloomberg was you know
also exploring uh serverless model
inferencing selden obviously was
pioneering
you know machine learning graphs uh
microsoft was in the process of you know
uh moving as um stack on top of
kubernetes
and then we had uh uh you know
google excel doing a lot of work around
10 tf serving tensorflow serving
so i think we decided you know okay
let's come together uh
form this you know group so that you
know we focus on this problem together
of you know machine learning inferencing
on top of communities and
geared towards 80 of the use cases right
so that led us into
into the serving side so you know there
is notebooks now there is distributed
training there is model serving
then you need something to to bring all
these things together in a more headless
automated fashion because
for a lot of the cases where you know uh
data scientists are manually
interacting with these uh tools and
platforms
there are in fact more number of cases
where you need automation
right where these things run in a
seamless loop right so that's where you
know keyflow pipelines came into
existence
and at this point need this way is
probably the most popular product
or project you know uh as part of the q
flow umbrella
so yeah it kept on evolving and yes as
you mentioned rightly
um just uh march of this year right we
had
our formal 1.4 uh you know
we wanted to go last year december
out but you know it's dotting guys
crossing the t's uh
ensuring that you know all the
stakeholders are happy uh
which led to the launch thanks got it
well i think it's really interesting
that um as i mentioned it it represents
all of this
cross-country or cross-company
collaboration um
but i also want to just reflect on the
fact that
um kubeflow is really uh you know it's
not an open source technology
in and of itself it's a collection
and i mean it's more than an
orchestration layer but i think the
orchestration layer
becomes a key part of what it's all
about
so but really kubeflow is representative
of or or includes lots of other open
source best-of-breed open source
projects as well
um so i want to like sort of
pull up this diagram that i have
that i pulled from one of your talks to
really sort of articulate
uh what the cube flow
system looks like and
anima let's uh talk through this for a
second because
i want to make sure that people have an
understanding of kind of all the
different things that kubeflow covers
and a bunch of the different open source
projects that
it encompasses or can be pulled into it
and integrated with it as well
no no thanks me so obviously i mean this
is
um you know in this shirt in some ways
you know depicts the problem
as well as you know why something like
qflo needed to exist right so
on one hand right the open source
landscape around data and ai has been
explosive
exploding right so you see a lot of
great projects coming around i mean
obviously you know
um tensorflow tensorflow serving
you know has has a strong uh momentum of
its own there is five dodge
actually boost inside hitler have been
out there for quite a while
uh and then you know there are
you know the the problem started
shifting towards you know
i don't have a solution for that in open
source to
hey you know it looks like there are too
many choices
plus you know i need to run all this on
communities right i need to establish
one single standard data ai
platform on top of kubernetes right and
and how do i bring all these
technologies together which ones to
choose
and then orchestrate them together right
so it's not only you know deploy them
but you know we need a consistent layer
to
uh work through them and have a seamless
transition from build to train to deploy
to manage
right so in an in it itself right i mean
as i mentioned right the core
region was you know let's run tensorflow
on kubernetes in a scalable manner then
you know moving towards
where other open source projects exist
right so
all the distributed training operators
which you see here around you know
beyond tensorflow it's quite torch then
there is mxnet
there is also chainer right depending on
the geography you are in if you are in
japan for example you know you will see
chainer very popular
right so that's also available as a
distributed training operator and then
there is an mpi which is based on uber's
forward approach for doing distributor
training where you have more
peer-to-peer thinking of the weights and
the gradients
instead of using you know the
tensorflow's parameter server approach
where
you have you know a parameter server
which is responsible for synchronization
of the weights and the gradients
so distributive training became you know
quite a bit of feel right and
you know this is a challenge which was
being faced by many vendors right hey
you know there are some users who want
to use tensorflow some who are using
pytorch some we want to use chainer some
want to use this algorithm for
distributed training
in tensorflow versus the tensorflow's
native algorithm so that's you know
the was the problem you know for solved
by the distributed or the training
operators
as i mentioned right i mean before
training you need a build platform where
you can have your initial models written
uh debugged etcetera right so that's
where jupiter notebooks come into
picture
and again this is instead of taking you
know jupiter hub as
is the approach here is uh to actually
provide our own implementation based on
kubernetes customer resource
architecture for jupiter notebooks what
we have seen is you know
it has done much better in terms of
scalability working you know nicely with
the underlying gpus persistent volume
claims etcetera
so so far you know very very popular
part of q flow as well
so you have jupyter notebooks to build
you have training operators to train
and then you know we go to the serving
side right so
then you have to deploy your trained
models right so
what are the options there right so you
know there was tensorflow serving if you
are you know using tensorflow models
um some folks are using for example onyx
so they are you know training in
tensorflow or pytorch and converting it
to onyx
seldon has been you know uh out there
and has been very popular
uh in terms of you know providing uh
model serving on top of kubernetes
and then you know as i was describing
right cap serving which
went in with the notion that you know
models consume heavy resources they
consume gpus these are expensive
resources and if your models are not
getting
traffic thou shall just you know scale
back to zero they should not be
consuming infrastructure
the second thing is you know how do you
do candidate rollouts av to a b testing
so that's where you know uh qfloor
serving
got focused in and so now that you have
all these different building blocks how
do you bring them together
right how do you orchestrate them
together in a more automated headless
fashion
so q4 pipelines you know uh fulfills
that particular gap for us where you can
actually go through the whole life cycle
and you know run distributor training
validate your models
deploy your models in production launch
scoring and monitoring clients using
pipelines
okay and did i did i read on a mesh that
pipelines
is built on argo behind the scenes
yeah so that's that's uh definitely you
know
another story so i'll go into it as
as much definitely the default q flow
pipelines engine is built on top of argo
another solid open source community
project right which came out of into it
right so as i was trying to complete
this story right so you have build
with jupiter train with all the
distributor training operators
tensorflow python sheet boost mxnet
chain or mpi
and then you know serve using uh you
know chip flow serving or certain core
right these are the two core serving
platforms and
qflo serving brings different runtimes
right for tensorflow python
shakeshibo circuit learn onyx and
media's triton
all together in a single serverless
platform on top of communities
you have these basic platforms for
pipelines right which is built on top of
argo
by default started you know providing
capabilities to orchestrate them
uh end-to-end machine learning life
cycle
and that's where also you know our
interest
in terms of you know beyond open source
contributions right
where we wanted to standardize uh in
terms of the pipelines right so watson
has been engaged heavily in terms of um
creating our watson ai pipeline story on
top of chief law pipelines
one thing which we have done is uh there
is
a heavy strategic alignment within ibm
around tecton as the underlying ci cd
technology
ibm cloud ci cd is based on top of
checked on
the open shift pipelines is based on top
of tecton so
we read what the whole q4 pipeline is
called to actually work on top of tecton
instead of argo
so it has less to do with you know the
technical capabilities of the two
platforms right i mean
it's not to say hey this is better or
this is better it's more that you know
for us
it made a lot more strategic sense given
that we have already standardized on
techtone
as the underlying ci cd technology
across our cloud
cloud and cloud native landscape so we
reload the whole q4 pipeline plane
engine to use tech talk and just to
clarify that's that's techton
t-e-k-t-o-n right not
not tekton the feature store that came
out of uber um
there's so many um funny name collisions
in in the space so many flows
tensorflow cube flow ml flow
uh i just wanted to clarify that it's
techton t k
to n correct yes you're right okay
okay and by the way i mean one thing
which is not now that you brought a
feature store right
one thing which is not mentioned on this
channel
is uh you know there was a partnership
initially between gojek
and google where they launched you know
feast and that's a project you know
which is
now heavily being driven um by
the gojek team out of singapore right at
this point and it has become very
popular in the feature store space in
fact you know the uber's tecton
has had a strong collaboration uh with
uh you know villain
who is the east project on the feature
store side and it's also available you
know as part of the keyflow install
as well oh great that's good to know
yeah we'll have to update this uh this
graphic to
reflect that one last thing i do want to
highlight is like you know
now for more advanced customers right uh
assuming you have all these in place
right you have the different
platforms to do the heavy lifting around
distributed training building your
models serving your models you have
pipelines to orchestrate that
more and more advanced customers are now
looking at you know governance
metadata lineage right so it's not only
sufficient to take
me from point a to point b right in
machine learning world
you know the outcome the final outcome
is you know a model deployed
in production but how is that model
behaving in production is in fact you
know more important because
you know you're not guaranteed that you
know the same model with the same input
two weeks later we'll get the same
output right and we have heard
situations
and you probably would have repeat that
you know quite a few people have lost
their jobs because you know the models
which was deployed in production right
started doing something
which it wasn't supposed to do right and
that's where you know having strong
and robust metadata auditing and lineage
capabilities become
very very important so you know there is
the
metadata project which is backing queue
flow pipelines right where you can trace
down the lineage of
every deployed model right back to the
point right okay this was the initial
data set you know this was
uh you know the change schema for this
data set this is uh
you know the new set of features which
have been added to this data set this
was trained using tensorflow version
this
and then you know using these hyper
parameters uh
for hyper parameter tuning and then
finally you know deployed on this these
were the scoring characteristics right
so in case
you know of any trouble or you know
there is a good news
but most importantly for your compliance
and auditing needs you need to be able
to trace back
to the very point like you know what
actually formed this model right so the
project backing queue flow pipelines
gives you this whole capability to trace
back the lineage you know for your
deployed models in production right at
every single step going back all the way
to
from where you started so that's the
metadata component here on the left
of the diagram yes yes and is
is there a model registry that's part of
that or how does kubeflow handle that
aspect of it
so modern registry is is surprisingly an
area where you know
we don't have a point you know at this
point an implementation out there right
typically it has been a strong request
from the community right so the metadata
registry is there the metadata registry
is more generic in the sense that you
know all the metadata around your data
sets models
but you know having the construct of a
model registry where you can actually
store the model bits and the bytes
versions them
etc right that part is is yet not there
are
there is a special interest group which
has been formed which is looking into it
quite a few members of the community are
right you know intermingling this and
bringing ml flow model registry
to work with these uh technologies right
so
um i mean that's always you know we are
seeing architectures where
you know you have model registry
projects out there in the open source
community and folks are you know
uh building their own reference
architecture combining the different
parts of the qfloor technology with
those
got it well that is um that's
quite the sprawling ecosystem um i mean
i think it's
it's remarkable that um you're working
to cover so many
um corners of the machine learning
workflow in one platform
um i mean obviously the idea is that
the whole system runs on top of
kubernetes so
um a company basically has to be bought
into kubernetes
in order to make use of this and of
course um
if a company isn't in kubernetes there's
sort of point solutions for
a lot of these functional pieces in
other world you know in other parts of
the open source world
some are very simplistic you know some
are
more built to be designed to be to have
systems built around them
but um i guess on that note just um you
know in terms of
sort of rolling out cube flow i'm
curious besides the kubernetes
requirement um are there other sort of
indicators
that you see that tells you whether a
team is ready
for kubeflow or not um i mean do you
have to implement the whole
thing or is there a easier way to kind
of get started with just bits and pieces
what what do you see in terms of um how
new users basically get on to the
kubeflow platform and
and when is the right time for them to
to start to consider a
framework or system like kubeflow
yeah very good question i think
you know it's a very mixed landscape
right i mean so the users who are coming
right there are some who are
much more advanced in terms of you know
some decisions they have already made
right so some users have already
standardized for example
on uh jupiter hub as well
you know their jupiter-facing platform
right or some users who have
actually you know gone ahead and have
you know partnered with a vendor
for a distributor training platform
right so
it's it's the point where you are in the
ai life cycle right so quite a few
users who have you know done more
advanced scenarios they are coming
for the later part of the life cycle
okay you know i have the basic
infrastructure for building my models
and training my models but i need
you know a platform to deploy my models
in
auction right and then more um
automated uh you know pipelines to
actually orchestrate this now that you
know we have
we have the end-to-end platform coming
together plus
you know since we are moving more and
more models in production i need more
advanced metadata and linear tracking
capabilities for auditing purposes
except
for compliance so but then there is a
huge set of users right who are
who probably know at this point
standardized on
on their cloud infrastructure have made
a decision that you know it's kubernetes
or openshift
uh right as their underlying platform
for any other workload they want to
bring on top right
and you know even though have they have
bits and pieces running they're looking
at you know can there be one turnkey
solution right
instead of you know spending a year to
build my
uh distributor training platform
spending next year to you know set up a
model serving platform then you know the
last year is you know when i look at
metadata
and linear tracking should you know is
there a way to actually cut that cycle
right can i standardized on one thing
and make that three years go in one year
where by the end of the year i have a
production ready
system in place right which is handling
all the parts of the lifecycle so
many users actually are coming from that
perspective
right now so these are you know the
consumers
and then there are vendors right so so
people who are trying to package
and resell more advanced solutions on
top of qfloor right so they're also you
know
uh you see uh like specifically uh for
us like within
watson right um as i mentioned right
the two areas which are of supreme
importance are
pipelines right um that's an area where
we
are actually investing quite a bit in
queue flow uh
as i was you know describing the second
area where we are actually you know
uh investing quite a bit is is serving
right and more so serving in the
serverless world right which is
essentially you know
if you know your models are not
consuming resources they should be long
and we have high scalability
requirements in terms of that
so we are working uh on the cab serving
community right besides being a
co-founder we are
amping up more and more contributions in
terms of building and bringing it closer
to what we expect from a works in
and then there are vendors who are
actually packaging and reselling the
whole q flow
as is right so you see you know all
sorts of flavors
happening
well let's um let's dig into to one of
these components
a little more deeply um you mentioned
the serving component was
um an important part of the whole cube
flow ecosystem
um what are the advantages of using
using kubeflow or kf serving um
why would why would i use that versus um
some other
serving uh technology that i could use
um if i was deploying my models maybe
walk us through some of the advantages
of
how the kf serving pizza that works and
um
and and what engineers should look for
in terms of benefits there
yeah um so i think um a i mean the first
and the foremost reason is like you know
are you in a situation where
you know you are seeing more and more
models rolling into production right
so um when you see more and more models
rolling in production right the things
which you need to account for
is hey is the resource over utilized is
it underutilized
i mean most of your models are probably
you know consuming uh expensive
resources like gpus etcetera so you want
to make sure that you know you're
prioritizing
uh you know the models which are getting
more traffic versus the ones right which
are probably you know sitting idle
then there are things like you know can
i support multiple protocols can i
support http can i support grpc
right do i have support for multiple
frameworks like you know
uh i have tensorflow models pytorch
models on x circuit learn actually boost
pml right the list goes on and on
right if i deploy these models on
on these platforms right can it actually
leverage the underlying gpu
infrastructure in the most optimized
manner
then you're looking at capabilities like
you know candy roll outs and a b testing
because machine learning world is so
experimental in nature you will be
producing
more and more models at a much shorter
frequency
as opposed to the application world
where you're probably doing you know
quarterly rollouts right if you're very
agile
and and they're supposed to be constant
you know the same input to the same
application is guaranteed to give the
same output you know three months later
not so in case of models right so you're
doing you know many many
roll outs so you know having strong
robust capabilities to do canary
rollouts and
while you are doing them right being
able to do
traffic splitting in traffic routing
right so you probably want to be in a
situation where you are rolling out new
versions of the model probably directing
five percent of the traffic
and then you know incrementally
increasing it uh
looking at the metrics right and as the
metrics are making sense that okay the
model accuracy is good there is no drift
you're then you know amping up the
traffic where you make the canon either
default
then you know the last the last leg
which is okay
now that you know you figured out
everything you know how to deploy this
model
in production and and you know do
progressive rollouts do traffic
splitting
and when the model is not getting
traffic you can scale back to zero
then okay how do i capture more advanced
metrics
right so some of these are you know more
i would say traditional infrastructure
level metrics like cpu gpu consumption
but then you know you start moving up
uh you know the request for a second the
latency of the model
but then the more advanced machine
learning metrics right um
is the model showing adrift right is
there an anomaly
uh are the model predictions getting
biased
you know can the model detect
adversarial attacks right
all these more advanced capabilities on
machine learning side right
so you know and then then there is
another piece right which is
most of the models right um
they typically have a preprocessor in a
post processor
right so that means you know like if you
take a look at the core model code it's
a predictor right which takes for
example
tensors in and gives you tensors out and
for all practical purposes that's the
thing which needs gpu that's the thing
which needs heavy compute power
but then you know your pre-processing
code which takes for example
an image from an end user converts that
image to a tensor
and then there is post processing which
you know gets the response from the
model which is again tensors converts
that to a text
you know they're all bundled in the same
they're all consuming the same gpu
and which is a problem right i mean
these pre-processes and post-processors
can actually run on you know cheaper
cpus versus gpus right
so does your platform provide those
capabilities so many of these problems
which existed and that's what you know
we are solving with care serving and and
you know
so far you know we're getting very good
feedback around you know solving some of
the real
hard uh you know production level
problems with kp serving
yeah and i want to ask about the metrics
and the
um sort of monitoring of your models
does kf serving have some
um standard way of instrumenting models
for
for performance metrics um sort of
evaluating the model quality
um what what is that monitoring does
that monitoring component plug directly
into kf serving or is that a different
piece of
the kubeflow framework it's a good
question right so
by default right so the kf serving stack
right it's built on top of
uh k native right now so that means you
know out of the box metrics so k native
has a very good
uh ecosystem integration with prometheus
and grafana right so a lot of the out of
the box metrics around
you know request tracing uh request per
second latency
you get out of the box you know you can
go to your graph on a dashboard you can
start seeing those metrics
you know as as and when you know your
departure is running along with these
monitoring stack now then comes you know
the more advanced metrics which are you
know more machine learning specific
metrics
talking about drift anomaly um
and and you know bias detection and
versatile detection right so
that's something you know which we have
what we have done in care serving is you
know we have implemented using you know
the standardized cncf uh
eventing protocol right uh
so you should be able to capture your
paleo blocks right
so like most of these things as you see
like if you're
predicting there is a drift you're
predicting there is an anomaly or you're
predicting you know
there is a bias more often than not you
require you know
a bunch of historical data versus you
know just making a decision based on
that one single transaction
right so that's that's the thing which
needs to be captured right so if your
model serving platform is deployed
it should be able to capture the request
coming in the response is going out
and then you know it has it has a
history of that and based on that you
can run analysis
for drift anomaly and other things so
for that you know we provide a
standardized implementation using the
cloud event cncf protocol
which you know you can configure uh
to send your payload logs and persist it
on a kafka or a canadian broker or a
database
right so it has all these capabilities
where you can purchase this
if you are persisting these logs on your
storage mechanism of your choice
then you know we provide uh advanced
algorithms right to run on top of those
payload logs right request responses to
give you analysis around drift
anomaly uh bias detection adversarial
detection and things like that
so it's the last leg is a bit more work
now can we package something which is
you know
let's say you know make a default choice
for the persistent storage
within care serving itself um
yes i mean there are there have been
thoughts like but more often than not
you know
you would see when customers are
actually
deploying something like this in
production they would have a storage of
choice
right hey i already have a relational
database running in production or i have
a kafka
eventing stream running in production
and i would like these to be sent
there versus you know uber storage
solution
so that's a don't bundle out of the box
and and you know
uh maybe we should uh you know there
have been thoughts around you know
should we create one advanced installer
if someone wants this out of the box
persistent storage mechanism right we
provide otherwise you know you are free
to configure on your own
got it and is there any interface at
that point between any of the
ethics and fairness projects you're
working at on ibm do they
integrate into the kubeflow system at
this point or are they completely
separate projects
no in fact uh we just uh you know
last month we did a pr
and have integrated ai explainability
360 which is now part of the linux
foundation a umbrella
and you know a very popular project in
its own right in terms of you know we
have been using with a lot of financial
industry customers so now that's
available out of the box and kf serving
so if you deploy cap serving and you
want you know explanations on your model
production
right and this can work at a per
transaction level right this is one of
those things which doesn't require
a historical sets of input and outputs
right for you to
be able to generate explanations right
obviously there are algorithms there
which can do that but
it can work on live individual
transactions and give you explanation so
that's integrated the second project
which we are
essentially uh you know working on and
hopefully you know we'll have a pr in
the next few weeks is our around
adversarial detection right so there's a
next foundation ai called
adversarial business toolbox this is
something you know which
uh we are working uh with darpa right
they are using it
as as part of their uh defense research
it's also you know being used by
microsoft uh general motors
right so that's one of the projects
which we are now integrating in q4
server right to do
the detection on your inputs right so
all
reports which are coming are they
adversarially impacted right is somebody
trying to fool the model
so yes um definitely i mean that's
that's an important
uh stream for us to make sure you know
these these come out of the box so
explainability is already there
the next one in the line is adversarial
robustness the last one which we will
integrate is ai fairness 360 for bias
detection and mitigation
that's great well these are some really
advanced
important aspects of this ecosystem that
we're all helping
to create um especially the ethical
unfairness bias detection um adversarial
hacking detection like these are all
really
interesting aspects and so i'm glad to
hear that
um you guys are already sort of thinking
forward as to how to integrate those
those bits into cube flow um so i wanted
to take a question from the community
rajeev is asking a question that i have
as well how well is kubeflow supported
comparatively on top of the cloud
platforms aws gcp azure
um is it better supported by any
particular vendor
or what should people expect or look for
if they're
if they want to deploy cube flow on
their own cloud on their own cloud
platform not their private cloud but
obviously um one of the big one of the
big three
hey rajiv um glad you asked that
question right uh
by the way i'm i'm from ibm right so
it's best supported
there you go but yeah i mean all the
major cloud providers right
um like including you know us if you go
to qfloor.org website right you will go
and see that you know aws is your
gcp you know they have very well
documented instructions in terms of
uh running on top of their communities
offering right for the most part
in fact you know what we see is most of
the community requests
are are coming where somebody is running
this on our cloud provider right so
uh you know obviously you know google is
is the core originator for queue flow
right but currently you know
amazon is heavily involved in terms of
contributions as well and they are
working you know
uh very hard in terms of ensuring that
you know the integration
of queue flow with aws services is is
pretty solid in fact you know with one
of our customers we actually
uh you know the services team of ibm
engaged in terms of getting queue flow
running on on top of
aws that was yara which is you know the
largest
uh you know fertilizer company out of
norway right so they are running for
example you know kevlar
uh on on top of aws and and then there
are quite a bit of customers with whom
we are working who are running queue
flow and ibm cloud right and
and i would say we have a pretty solid
integration and if you are interested
right
uh one repository which i would say is
you know
if you're getting started um you know
it's github.com
ibm slash qfloor dojo
that actually you know takes that you
know very starter based approach
starting from the scratch going all the
way deploying it
on ibm cloud and then you know
ensuring you're working with those
services but q4.org website is your best
choice right i mean you would get
very solid documentation from all the
cloud providers yeah
excellent and i discovered the the ibm
kubeflow dojo resource as well in
preparation for this chat with you and
it was very helpful so
i'll make sure that we put that that
link in the chat here so that folks can
take advantage of that resource as well
um
well that's that's great on a mesh um
we're out we're at 45 minutes
um i just wanna wanted to basically ask
you a couple community questions
um before we sign off um what are ways
that
uh people can get involved in the
project i know open source projects are
always looking for
additional committers um or
or people at least to you know try to
try the project
and sort of report issues that they find
are there any other more focused ways
that
the community can be involved um in the
kubeflow project that are especially
meaningful
meaningful to you right now
yeah definitely i think obviously we are
looking for a lot of help
right so i think one of the things with
q flow is you know the sum is greater
than the parts right so there are many
parts right
but the reason it became uh
big is you know getting this whole
end-to-end life cycle
in one single goal through one open
source project you know
and that's the piece right where i would
say you know quite a bit of help is
needed to ensure that you know that
consistent
way of bringing all the different flow
components together deploying them
managing them upgrading them
uh you know remains solid uh as we move
along you know there is
obviously more domain focused areas like
you know if you are more interested in
the serving side production machine
learning serving side
or you know on the pipelines or in the
distributed training side these are all
different work groups which have been
formed so if you go to queue flow slash
so in the q flow github blog there is a
community a project called community if
you click on that
you know there is a there is a yaml file
at the root of that which is called the
workgroups.yaml or wgs.yaml
you know all the different work groups
which are listed the people who are
leading it when are they having the
meetings
right and you know pointers to the slack
channels so obviously you know you want
to be in the queue flow
slack workspace and each of these
projects have their slack channels
but more importantly if you're trying to
figure out you know which is the work
group and the participating companies or
the leading companies behind all these
different domains
i would say you know that's a good place
to start to figure out and you know it
has the email ids it has the people who
are leading these
plus you know when the community
meetings are happening for those
specific ones right so you can you can
join that
that's great i love it you have your own
yaml file um
for working groups how meta
well um i hope that you you get some a
lot of interest
in the kubeflow project um from this
conversation
i know that our community is interested
and
um you might even get some committers um
hopefully as well
but um what what's a good place for
folks to
get in touch with you on a mesh is the
best place in the
slack group for kubeflow or are you on
twitter
i'm on twitter twitter is my first name
and last name right so anime
sing right that's that's my handle
so hopefully you know uh it's it's easy
to reach out definitely
my github handle is the same you know
anime saying okay
so that's another way right and
definitely you know i'm mostly available
in all the key flow slack channels right
if you want to reach out from that
perspective so
yeah looking forward to uh you know more
contributors coming and and taking this
project to greater heights right we we
see an endless opportunity we already
have a huge number of enterprise
customers right
who are either using shoe flow as a
whole or parts of q4 on which they have
standardized and and
i see you know there is still a great
amount of potential which needs to be
tabbed
right and and thing like you know i was
mentioning feature store right which
has yet not become you know total
mainstream
how we are seeing you know next year we
are we are seeing you know quite a bit
of customers as they have now become
more advanced they're looking for
something like you know feature store
which can give them a consistent set of
features which they can use for training
for their deployed models in production
uh and and more technologies like that
like so there is a project
called you know captain and q flow
around hyper parameter tuning but then
there is an arm of it which is around
auto ml right so neural architecture
search
so a lot of more advanced areas right
which are which are coming up
and you know if you're interested also
you know more futuristic research
oriented things
it's also a great place to come and and
yeah yeah
yeah that's great well i'm sure your
kodai group is always hiring
and uh so we'll put the word out for you
amongst the community
i've seen lots of great engineers um go
through your group
in the last you know a bunch of years
and contribute to awesome projects so
so that's been neat to see and um yeah
it's been great to chat with you anime
thanks for taking the time to come and
share with the community thanks thanks